hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the Paul
Morphy saga and we have arrived at the
first American chess congress now as if
you've seen the previous video you know
that morphe finished his law school he
got his degree to practice law but he's
still too young to actually practice law
he still has to wait for one more year
and he decided to use this year to brush
up on his chest knowledge to challenge
some very strong opponents and his uncle
Ernest Murphy had a lot to do with this
he he tried to publish more fees games
in magazines he tried to organize
matches against Murphy and some very
strong opponents but it seems that word
of morphe defeating Leventhal reached
far and no one accepted their offer it
was if you win against Murphy you
received $300 and if you lose you you
get $100 even if you lost just that
cover your traveling expenses but no one
accepted this offer and then mr. daniel
willard fist the editor of the chest
month monthly magazine and well earnest
more feet more fees uncle and some other
very prominent people decided that they
should organize a chess meeting that
just get together a chest congress and
so the the first american chest congress
was born well the idea it took a lot of
time before it actually came into motion
and well the talking about it started
sometimes during 1856 and the congress
was held in 1857 now the problem is of
course Murphy received the invitation
alongside with some others very strong
grandmasters well I grandmasters chess
masters there was no Grandmaster title
at a time but the problem is something
happened and morphe declined in the
invitation Murphy's father along the
morphine as the story goes there there
there's not a lot of detail about this
but it seems that he was walking
somewhere I imagine in New Orleans maybe
in the marketplace maybe maybe somewhere
and he wanted to talk to a certain
gentleman and when the gentleman turned
around he cut morphia
well more of his father's eye on the
brim of his Panama hat now if you're
like me and you don't know what a brim
is actually I have a photo here so that
there is a seed that's a
of a Panama hat I don't know if this is
actually a fan of my hat maybe it isn't
but that's a brim so like the the edge
the blade of the hat so probably he has
seen something something like good sir
do you maybe know the time and then when
the window gentleman turned around then
he cut along those eye and well it was
it was a small cut that the problem is
it got infected and morphus father died
from the infection and well due to that
unfortunate event and morphe declined
the invitation to the american chest
congress and he said that he was going
to attend to the other matters now with
the family and everything but his uncle
Ernest Murphy was persistent and they
managed the top morphine to going to New
York to play in the first American chess
congress so he boarded a steamer than
the train he arrived in New York and he
arrived in the New York chess club which
was actually formed by this gentleman
here American master James Thompson in
1839 so if any of you have been to the
New York chess club or maybe or maybe
even member suddenly of chess club this
is the gentleman that that form that I
imagine there's even a nice photo of him
hanging there maybe if you are a member
members of the New York chess club maybe
do do share in the comment section below
is there such a nice photo of him in
your in your New York chess club yeah
morphia arrived and the he started
playing games so way before the the
tournament even began he he really
obliterated a lot of people and people
decided that morphe was even amongst the
favorites to win the tournament even
though out of all the participants none
of them ever actually met morphe only
one person there judge McNew knew who
more he was in person so it was a it was
really an exciting moment they heard
about morphe strengths they heard about
his his match against xi all his games
against Rousseau against earnest morphe
amongst others who was also a very
strong player and they they didn't know
what was where the stories exaggerated
was morphe actually that's strong but
today we're gonna find out and so to
tell you a bit more about the tournament
the games started at 9:00 a.m. and then
they finished at 12 a.m. so only if the
players did
want to play so if one player said okay
I'm tired then he could take a one-hour
break or if not they could just continue
playing the problem is there was no
there were no clocks so even even if you
thought for a very long time you could
just think for as much as you wanted
unless unless there's a rule unless a
player like thought really long on every
move then an arbiter could intervene and
then he could set a limit to half an
hour per move which sounds crazy by
today's standards but that's how chess
was played in those days and there were
a lot of very interesting things about
actually selecting the the well the
system for pairings for example the
Indus turn and they use the pairing
system or they also used in the 1851
London tournament which was introduced
by Howard Stanton and basically the all
the opponents are chosen randomly which
was a problem in the 1851 London
tournament because a lot of favorites
were already paired against each other
in round one and since it's a it's an
elimination tournament now it's a
knockout system the crowd was displeased
that a lot of players didn't get to play
more games so they thought maybe they
could go around this but then in the end
they decided now we're just gonna let it
happen and whoever plays who is gonna
play that person and also I prepared
something for you that I think you're
really gonna enjoy these are the five
books that Morphy read up until this
point in his life so these are the only
five books that I don't know if he read
them he had them so these are the books
as you can see chess studies by Horowitz
and Kling a lot against a collection of
Lionel Kissel it's key the chess
tournament by Howard Stanton chess
players handbook and companion also by
Howard Stanton and the treatise of the
game of chess by William Lewis so those
are the five books that Morphy had
before embarking on this legendary
tournament so if you're still you know
deciding whether to take up studying
chess maybe grab a book or two remember
it only takes five books to go to a nice
tournament so I did being said we're
gonna talk a bit more about
and about everything that happened here
but now let's check out the game so Paul
Charles Murphy vs. the founder of the
New York chess club James Thompson
strong American chess master let's see
let's see what happened here
so more feet with the white pieces opens
with efore and also I would just like to
mention this seems to be game one of
their match but it could also be Game
two some sources say that this is Game
one some sources say that this is Game
two but I'm gonna go with the official
one from chess Gamescom and from the the
book on morphine by Louis that this is
actually game 1 so let's check it out we
have c5 and each match was going to be
there were 16 players so 16 players in
all for this bigger tournament the
important one and it's in it's a
knockout system so 16 then 8 are
eliminated then 8 play each other then
for our limited and so on until we have
the final winner so c5 and Knight to f3
the Sicilian is on the board we have
Knight to c6 and d4 now now morphe
strikes in the center c captures knight
characters and east 6 at the time on all
variation so the match is based at 5
games at first to win 3 so best best out
of five basically and Bishop to e3 by
morphe continuing development nowadays
Knight to c3 is that is the preferred
line but okay Bishop e3 with Bishop to
e7 Knight to f6 again would be preferred
today Bishop to e7 is a bit of a timid
move so to say Knight to c3 and here we
have h6 by Thompson
and it is as of move six that
disposition has never occurred again so
never again intercessory was this
position reached over okay Bishop d3
Morphy continues developing pieces and
now d5 which is kind of a principled
move but not really yes you are striking
in the center and we always say if you
can play d5 in the Sicilian you should
always play it but this is not the one
such case and it's a white is ahead in
development the black still has a
Knights to develop before castling so
this doesn't really work and here morphe
punishes it accordingly so feel free to
pause the video and the punish thompson
for his insolence in the opening
while I have a nice if of my water so
for those of you who are able to do
congratulations on spotting that d5 is a
bit too early here and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
Bishop to b5 Bishop to b5 is a beautiful
move that wins the pawn and that's a
pretty big big deal
the problem is if you continue with
something like let's say you character
upon here then you get a knight captures
on c6 you grab the piece you are already
attacking Queen and after an ice queen
trade here you have to win back your
piece but the angel Bishop captures with
Czech wins material here and it's it's a
game over for blacks so what else can
you do you could play Queen d7 now okay
the knight isn't really pinned but it
kind of is so a white will just castle
here and now you still have to start you
either have to start playing something
like a six b5 kick or kick away the
bishop or you can start by Knight f6 and
then try to maybe castle but if I will
just be very strong here you don't allow
castling and after 94 characters
captures you're gonna go Queen g4 and
already black is in a lot of trouble
you're threatening to pick up the Jeep
on here if black castles then Bishop
captures and h6 is an idea so a terrible
position for black so here Thompson I
realized that he had no other option but
to play Bishop to d7 and now you can
simply grab upon which is what more if
he did with ecad % e5e captors and
Knight characters on d5 so a bit of an
over aggressive approach by Thompson and
the Morphy capitalizes on it Knight to
f6 continuing development Murphy
captures Knight captures with Czech
Bishop captures and c3 now defending the
knight here with castles Morphy castles
as well and now Queen to c7 very nice
move getting the Queen into the game the
rooks are now connected and Queen to a
for now morphe puts additional pressure
on the night here and here look ft 8 by
Thompson more of a well tactically more
sound approach would be Knight captures
and e4 but it requires a lot of a Lada
calculating Bishop character Sun b7 and
now
rook F d8u you go after the the
disappear and after Bishop capture Cindy
for you played Bishop captures on d4
bishop moves and now des bishop moves
threatens the h2 pawn now g3 and rogue
d2 Thompson is still down upon but at
least he he got a very active rook on d2
so this this would have been preferred
about okay rook F e8 and the now rook a
to be 1 by morphe put your rooks and
open files as they say rook to e4
now pinning the night as the queen is on
a four and now morphe just brings the
Queen back Bishop captures first Bishop
characters and now Queen to c2
we have Bishop to e5 again putting
pressure on the h2 point and the g3 now
now blocking the dark square bishop and
now that morphe created some holes here
Thompson plays correctly and play
special characters on d4 it's now time
to part with the bishop pair Bishop
captures on d4 we have seek after sandy
for Bishop CalPERS and d4 seems like a
more reasonable move the problem is
after this row comes the e I do have a
very nice control of the e2 square which
is a light square will not be easy to
get away from there and you have this
beautiful bishop on this diagonal so
black would definitely have compensation
for the pawn here so after Bishop
captures on d4 we have C capture some d4
instead now the bishop nicely prevents
the rook from doing anything here and d5
is coming so by capturing with the C
pawn morphe also created a past deep on
we have Queen to e7 now getting the
Queen out of the way as you cannot move
the bishop here due to the pin here
Queen to a5 was a little bit better
since it also guards the d5 square
prevents d5 but Thompson decided to go
for this Queen to e7 move morphe
immediately played d5 right it's a must
we have pushed back the b7 and now
Bishop to c5 now grabbing more space
with an attack on the Queen problem is
Thompson has rook to c8 but it doesn't
seem like more fees bothered by this he
just he just trades into an endgame
Bishop captures an e7 rook captures and
c2 and now Bishop goes back to a 3
guards the b2 pawn so we have b5 already
Samson is
threatening be for to capture the
chiffon III but now rook fe1 threatening
to win back the rook at the window rook
we have f5 blocking and now f3 again
forcing the trade we have rook captures
anyone with Czech captures and did not
look the D to hear more Thompson goes
for the d5 pawn but now these six so
that's already a nicely protected pass
pawn on d6 with a5 procuring b4 now
again to trap the bishop and now Bishop
to c5 of course not allowing this end
before we look the East 7 now finally
this rook evolves into a pig and now
going after the bishop and now it's hard
to decide what to do here strongest is
Bishop to c6 but also Bishop c6 you kick
away the bishop the bishop will go
somewhere you can start pushing maybe
now after you after you deal with with
with some points here it would be it
would be an improvement to what Thompson
played however Thompson decided to go
rook to d5 he said ok let's let's trade
bishops and then we're gonna go go into
a row component game where my king is
very close so I shouldn't have problems
stopping this pawn and you're only up
one point the problem is he missed the
tactic here but feel free to pause the
video and try to find it while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on grabbing the free
porn and for those of you who just want
to enjoy show its Bishop captures and
before this is what Thompson missed and
you know it happens to everyone you know
you just miss upon a captures there is
no better move and only now rope
characters here and now Murphy is in a
rockin game but he's up to pawns king of
faith Thompson starts improving the
position of the King but now the
cold-blooded Rugby 7 now offering a pawn
for this pawn which would create two
connected passed pawns on the Queen side
rugby for defending but now King f2
saying okay I'm gonna go after your rook
and here for the lack of a better move a
rock out for Sundy sex rook a person
before rugby to check and King III more
if he gives up the h du Pont to gain
activity as his rook is nicely guarding
the b2 point and he wants to start
pushing his
a pond which is of course a winning idea
we have grouped at first on h2 in the
now a four we have looked the c2 now
preparing to bring the roux back to help
out with the defense of the point a 5
we have ripped the c5 hoping for a six
that put the room behind the passport
but more if he beats him to it he puts
his rook behind the passport and now
a-six a-seven and a-eight is coming so
king e7 with b4 now the other point
starts marching forward as well rook c8
b 5 we have rook to b8 but now a6 saying
that ok you're welcome to grab the pawn
but you know after I push a 7 there is
no stopping a8
so after a6 King these 7 was played but
now b6 and here again it's the same idea
so King to c6 going after the pawn but
now rook but now just b7 and now a 78
it's coming there's no stopping that I
think the b6 was played to prevent this
but still doesn't help a 7
we have roped ie8 with check King to f4
and only now King captors and b7 black
seems to have gobble up both of the
pawns but it's not a problem since this
King is much too far away to help out
with the defense of the King side pawn
so morphe just ends Allah ends it with
point 8 Queen we have rook captures rook
captures King captures and here after
King captures on a 448 it was in this
position that James Thompson resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here after he moves like the King
be 7 years just gonna gobble up these
pawns captures and then after let's give
me 5 captures here you're gonna go here
or g6 for that matter doesn't really
matter and you're gonna start pushing
the pawn and win the game very easily so
of course Thompson saw that and he
decided to resign here so game 1 of the
dare match the first game played in the
American chess congress by Paul Murphy
ends in Murphy's favor we're gonna see
how the others go and it's gonna be it's
gonna be really awesome and there's
gonna be a lot of really awesome stuff
which we're gonna discuss later if
you're interested this game lasted only
15 minutes so it took morphe 15 minutes
the to be Thompson here of course
they didn't have a time limit on the
moves but as you can see they played
they played fairly quickly and now the
the two favors to win the tournament
were of course Louis Paulson and Paul
Morphy after you know people really
heard about how strong Morpheus and they
were really hoping that two of them
don't meet in first round which they
didn't and the Paulson also started
winning his games against Calthrop and
well we're gonna get back we're gonna
get to that in in a few videos but just
to give you something to look forward to
Paulsen organized simultaneous
exhibition a blindfold simultaneous
exhibition against four players and he
invited more feet to be one of the
players where a person will play
blindfold and morphe gladly accepted his
offer but he said only if I also play
blindfold so this game is recorded no
we're also gonna show that game but when
you know when we get to that and also
here's a very nice photo of all the
participants of the I almost said of the
Grantchester of the first American chess
Congress here they are could be also a
nice photo challenge for you try to
identify all the players there as you
can see there are 16 of them or if it's
too difficult maybe maybe just try to
spot Morphy and Paulson and do share
your findings in the comments below of
course so yeah that's that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it the first game we
were covering in the American chess
congress and we're gonna cover all the
games more if he played so you know
prepare for that sir I think I really
covered a lot of things in this video
we're not gonna go into so much details
in the other videos but if needed we
definitely will so yeah I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Abdullah Roger
Thomas Walter Frank combs Gary McGowan
and Brian strong for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I'm thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
well continuing the Paul Morphy saga so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day